Nano scale Hunter Killer Robots powered
by light are here finally we're all very
aware of the dangers of disease-causing
microbes the problem is when we fight
them they fight back bacteria for
example have developed resistance to
every traditional antibiotic but a team
at Rice University has created an
incredible new weapon tiny machines that
spin at 2 million times a second
drilling into bacterial walls literally
ripping them apart they get their energy
from blue light at a wavelength of 405
nanometers so they're effective anywhere
you can shine that light researchers say
they'll be especially effective in
treating burn victims whose infections
are usually near the surface of the skin
and they're working on Nanobots that can
go deeper into the body run on infrared
light and even destroy fat cells so
watch out bacteria we've got tiny
Terminators they're coming for you
Vsauce one story down five to go this is
mind blow it turns out neanderthals had
awesome meat parties well often thought
of as slow dim-witted cavemen recent
Studies have shown neanderthals actually
had a sophisticated social structure
lived in larger groups than previously
thought and developed complex strategies
for hunting huge beasts archaeologists
who work out of a castle in Germany have
just analyzed the site of an Ice Age
Neanderthal camp and found the remains
of 70 straight tusked elephants that
were three times the size of modern
elephants and 62 percent bigger than a
T-Rex considering the size of the
animals the caloric intake of the people
and other factors they determined that
after killing these massive creatures
using only cunning and stone tools they
consumed four tons of the meat in a
giant Feast that fed 350 people for a
week so next time you've got some family
over think of Neanderthal meat parties
say hello to 3D printing with
holographic sound if you've got a 3D
printer you might know that while
they're really cool they can sometimes
be slow but what if you could press a
button and instantly print an object or
a body part acoustic waves exert forces
when they hit solid objects and by
manipulating a series of holographic
ultrasound Fields scientists at the Max
Planck Institute in Germany were able to
finally tune the force landscape
creating 3D printed materials in one
shot it's especially effective at
manipulating biological material
including living cells and the process
can revolutionize construction
techniques ultrasound therapy and more
importantly tissue engineering one day
you may have a vat grown organ created
instantly using holographic sound
let's talk about this new ice ice is ice
right wrong for one thing it's
technically a mineral like quartz or
diamonds secondly the ice we're familiar
with is called ice1h but there are at
least 19 different phases of ice and
scientists are discovering new kinds all
the time like a couple weeks ago a team
at Cambridge University used a technique
called ball Milling where regular ice
crystals were subjected to extreme sheer
force by being shaken in a steel Jar
full of metal ball bearings what came
out was something new they call it
medium density amorphous ice or MDA it's
the first form of ice known to have the
same density as liquid water so you know
how ice cubes float in a soda this won't
even weirder when MTA recrystallizes
back into ordinary ice it releases a
tremendous amount of heat it's so
strange the discovery questions are very
understanding of the nature of liquid
water but unfortunately you can't whip
this revolution missionary new ice up in
your freezer to create it you first have
to freeze the jar and metal balls in
liquid nitrogen at negative 196 degrees
Celsius that's cold
here's a fun guy that just might boost
your brain neuroscientists at the
Queensland brain Institute in Australia
have extracted biologically new
compounds from the lion's mane mushroom
when tested in mice the substances
doubled axial length in brain cells led
to significantly enhanced memory and
improved cognitive performance they work
by greatly increasing the size of
cellular growth cones which help brain
cells sense their environment and build
connections to other nearby neurons
according to the team the compound could
revolutionize treatments for Alzheimer's
and other neurodegenerative diseases
humans are not mice though so don't
start guzzling this stuff thinking
you'll be a Galaxy brain right away
the solar system is glowing and no one
knows why astronomers at project Sky
surf figure this out when they try to
calculate exactly how dark it is in
outer space they analyze 200 000
pictures from the Hubble telescope and
removed the glow from all the planets
Stars asteroids and other astronomical
sources but somehow a tiny amount of
light was still there the equivalent of
10 fireflies steadily shining across the
entire Sky it's like turning off all the
lights in a dark room and noticing that
the walls were suddenly glowing because
the glow is everywhere it's hard to
figure out the source but the best
candidate may be dust that drifts across
the solar system from the tales of
comets some long dead if that's the case
this dust shell would be a new addition
to what we know of the architecture of
the solar system nobody's officially
named it yet so maybe you could be the
first I recommend the name Kevin
and now for the telephone designs of
1977 accent
early American
Elite
sculptura
[Music]
celebrity
Mediterranean
Optique
commemorative Elite
thanks to all of my patrons for bringing
back mind blow join the bring back mind
blow project for ad-free episodes and a
ton more rewards and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]
oh